la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
vigier merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
nos agriculteurs sont à nouveau dans la
rue
et pour cause vous les mettez à la rue
vous les oubliez vous les abandonnez
vous les ignorez vous n'écoutez pas
leurs cris d' alerte et de souffrance
il traverse une grave crise structurelle
qui a trop duré
or ils sont une force vive de notre pays
il travaille notre terre ils nous
nourrissent ils entretiennent nos
espaces
ce sont des chefs d'entreprises qui
créent de l'emploi
comment pouvez vous les laisser de côté
comment votre majorité peut-elle refuser
de discuter d'une proposition de loi
présentant des solutions concrètes pour
nos agriculteurs
comment votre majorité peut-elle en
commission des affaires économiques
rejetez article par article
nos propositions qui sont
l'aboutissement d'un important travail
en lien avec nos agriculteurs il est
grand temps de redonner leur fierté à
nos agriculteurs
il est grand temps de retrouver une
agriculture compétitive performantes et
innovantes
il est grand temps que nos agriculteurs
vivent du fruit de leur travail et
obtiennent des prix rémunérateurs
monsieur le premier ministre
à quand une véritable politique agricole
française
il est grand temps d'agir merci
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt le seul
média monsieur le député vous avez
conclu votre question avec les grands en
pleine politique agricole nationale
j'ai déjà entendu ça sur un cintre monde
de rang et dans dans la voix et dans
l'expression d'un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques
si vous pensez qu'on peut se passer de
l'europe aujourd'hui avec 9 milliards
d'euros dead
si vous pensez comme vous l'aviez fait
d'ailleurs au moment où vous étiez
responsabilité que le budget européen
pour l'agriculture pouvait être réduit
c'est votre sincérité et vous devrez
vous expliquer devant les agriculteurs
quant à vos projets de loi que vous avez
défendu monsieur le député ya un
principe qui est dans ce projet doit qui
consiste à trouver des solutions et nous
sommes prêts à en discuter
sauf que l'essentiel de ce projet de loi
monsieur le député consiste à faire des
baisses de charges
donc vous savez très bien que ciblés
comme vous les avez ciblé
elles sont impossibles à mettre en
oeuvre compte tenu du droit européen qui
est aujourd'hui celui que vous avez
aussi négocier à l'échelle européenne
vous me dis qu'après que ces baisses de
charges sont gagés puisque ce sont des
dépenses budgétaires et vous les avez
gâché c'est votre droit sur une
augmentation de la tva et de la csg
c'est sur ce point là que nous avons une
différence c'est sur ce point là que
nous avons une divergence et je vous
rappellerai monsieur le député que
contrairement à ce que vous dites sur
les baisses de charges si aujourd'hui
dans l'aviculture
on dépasse les 1 vers galles 9 8
milliards d'euros de baisses de charges
c'est parce que a été pris on était pris
des décisions par cette majorité pour
faire bénéficier de l'agriculture
les baisses de charges et le pacte de
responsabilité ce que je vous le
rappelle monsieur le député vous n'avez
jamais fait et j'avais mis en oeuvre
donc sur ce sujet
si on veut être cohérent si on veut
donner de l'espoir aux agriculteurs il
faut trouver de vrais ce même s'il est
pas faire de promesses la palette